I lost my backing for this video you get
to enjoy it without my face I know
that's impossible but let's try enjoy
house got read nice welcome back to
summer Scrabble net on nice let's
continue shall we shall we good
just you look a little tired eh it's
perfect
just relax and let me play oh yeah can
we unlock no we can't [ __ ] all right we
got to go ^ all right we're here we need
to get 1500 so let's do that but first
we must get our ducks ride ducks ride
alright what does this guy want help me
cover fi baldness I can help you with
out here you go sir what lot of hair
there you go
what's that mermaidman doing well what
the [ __ ] are you doing no no my dog why
how de how dare you touch my dock
gigantic there you go dad
that's how it huh he humped him to death
that's awesome
and he became a steak I'll have my duck
eat it and then throw I wanted to feed
em oh well I can reproduce war no
problem
someone help I've been tied to this
pillar and left to rot well that's just
too bad man well have a friend
how about i how about we make it explose
sim and then we attack it oh why does
the ducks have to punished every time
the Ducks have to be the one all right
how about we make a deadly dot best duck
ever duck
destroyer of world all right anyway we
got enough so we can unlock the Green
Lantern story so the story is actually
fun so let's do it I don't actually
don't know the Greenline story my father
was a test pilot he died when I was
still very young as long as I can
remember I always wanted to fly
maxvill dad hell Jordan way to fly okay
how should we make him fly I think a
rocket diaper it's like ha ha ha ha ha
thank you go sir what who doesn't want a
rocket diaper there we go how do I use
it
whoa whoa how about a rocket duck what
is that dude holy [ __ ] whoa
fly I don't know a [ __ ] plane Adam
god damn it
oh there you yes so smart oh yeah I know
this I know this I
the movie sinestro scores are powered by
fear create something that makes people
afraid what that's what I was gonna
write what do you think what yeah it
right create something that reminds
people of love I don't know okay ah yes
the red lantern curves led by horrifying
atrocious join the fueled by rage cry
something that made people angry or
makes people angry
I don't know politics hey yeah
yes hahaha spread hope create something
that gives people hope
friendship fried squid close enough
matzah what gives people hope see no one
knows bugs
oh yeah she create a pug look what it
work
uh-huh and finally Indigo tribe which
was founded by the same Abin Sur they
gave me my ring the ending of tribe
healed by a compassion okay let's try
hug again you never know know they can
all kill it it worked
punks are in the solution everything
they're the new ducks if the toughest
challenge covers of ever face gosh that
sure sounds scary it was but it's over
now
I know Maxwell says your power is a lot
like mine I bet you'd make a great great
black go thanks mr. Jordan and go we're
doing great
I'm proud of you for not doing [ __ ]
which one do you want to see more a
Batman Superman or green lanten what's
that Superman okay sure whatever you say
you know we need to do a lot of favours
in the Superman one cuz I stuff he's
wearing a Batman shirt
what a dick this looks familiar grab
this star I climb
what what let's make a pug baby I'm
carrying it of course why would I write
it that's just stupid
there we go double pug pug section
what's his unicorn doing here there we
go yes okay beef-witted what the [ __ ] is
I hello
I secured this thing ever let's be star
of all this is my app by the way we have
a pocket in case you didn't know oh oh
oh okay how do I do it
attack edge attacking pug there we go
miss one but but I killed it what is the
what what do you guys want I wish we had
some stars to look at sky
nail net uh stop-attack it's all
beautiful
you're talking about my pug tried to
shoot the soccer ball it's called a
football god damn it
Americans mail it good
give me a fast opponent to race against
go duck why what's wrong with fast duck
what do you want
hey I was gonna outrun him if he's
holding him uh oh [ __ ] oh hey I was gone
this game is just two random seriously
it's [ __ ] awesome yes so awesome so
awesome that's given a princess
really that's a princess crown of course
oh whatever
show me what I look like kind of like
this really why would he attack the
mirror shoot him laser pug [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ] pug away no he came a little
dust what the [ __ ] are you doing alright
I don't cha finer you escaped
you'll never contain me ACK oh is it
like a genie
alright coca-cola another khatola more
colas yeah I thought is that more
Castillo's yeah more catalyst okay now
it's getting ridiculous Couture Allah
Allah why spell Cthulhu
what is that what can I write it how do
I write it
please let me write it ah god damn it
I'm riding him kill him what how did I
do that
holy [ __ ] cthulhu's Balham power good
throws ball up sexiness how you doing
what's going on here why is that woman
running this area is so dank she killed
herself
well Yolo what is love oh poor baby I'm
sorry what do you want I was a baby yeah
I have a bat the baby kill himself
everyone is killing the south when I
come here
why what is go I wrote the game I can't
move what I broke the game
good job pills goddamnit
it's you a Mikoto lo why you're hitting
me now dammit khatola hey mister seal I
need something to crack it open its a
walrus
I want a walrus oh my god Wow mr. walrus
ha alright I am my hipster laser walrus
she shoots moustaches no stop dying how
the hell does he shoot month mustachioed
what the [ __ ] oh nice
he shoots moustaches are you [ __ ]
kidding me why does he shoot moustaches
that is genius
alright adventure all right fess I hope
you enjoyed watching this episode leave
a like if you did it helps me out a lot
I really appreciate all the support it's
awesome I can play games for you bros
and and that's what I do I love it thank
you both so much for watching
it's a sky remover today I'll see you in
the next one
love you boys
yes